generally call me thank you for joining
us you're welcome a simple question is
brexit going to happen on the 29th of
March 2019 at the moment it looks like
it and we will challenge this government
on the six tests and if they don't meet
them then we will vote against it to be
clear it might not happen on the 29th of
March
well given the policy that you're
putting forward our policies are to
protect jobs and living standards and to
ensure that the regulations on workers
rights consumer rights the environment
are met in any agreement that was made
with you of them therefore we've set
these six tests down and in Parliament
we will vote accordingly to those six
tests but if they don't meet the success
and other hurdles are not met then we'll
vote against them and breaks it might
not happen when it's currently jus under
live in March 29th we will then vote
against it if it doesn't meet our six
tests does it sound like breaks it might
is definitely going to happen I mean
this is the many viewers many of your in
voters I mean just across the water
Birkenhead majority leave voters how do
you explain to them having put in a
manifesto that you'll respect referendum
that it might not happen do you starting
down a path that means we're starting or
not were a long way down a path of
saying that that referendum put a
challenge to the government to negotiate
article 50 they've completely failed to
do that and we've said that in any
agreement with the European Union you
have to protect our trade relationship
with Europe you have to protect the
Northern Ireland Board you have to
protect you Nationals and you have to
protect those vital conditions at work
and in our food so you'll have seen the
standing ovation for your shadow brexit
secretary after his speech and I'll just
read out his quotes if the PM still
fails and she refuses general action
quotes options must include campaigning
for a public vote and nobody is ruling
out to remain as an option to stand by
those words those are the words of the
motion those the words of emotions is
supported by the National Executive and
the Shadow Cabinet and that is what is
being voted on in conference dress
nobody is ruling out remain as an option
clearly with those words care put that
in because it's what's there in the
motion and and so we will challenge this
government and if
they don't meet our six Tests will vote
against it and then we will take it from
there the priority though isn't the
arcane wording of motions it's not just
arcade is it mr. Corbett it's about
opening sitting out remain as an option
about let's go back on some it's about
jobs referendum it's about a job the
results about jobs developing Saunders
every 2017 in response to Tony Blair
referendum happened let's respect the
result and Oxley happened respect the
results and now nobody's ruling out
remain is an option that is there in the
motion as a discussion will take place
depending on the outcome of these
negotiations are but we're getting into
slightly hypothetical territory here
it's all motion that gets into the
hypothetical territory I mean I think
the point is that there was zero chance
of this if you backing the idea of
remain and now there is a chance you've
opened up and from the chairs from your
membership you've opened up the chance
of bricks it not happening our party is
determined to protect people's jobs
living standards and ensure that trade
relationship with your of you got a Tory
party that's trying to do some
sweetheart deal with Trump which will be
very damaging
hibari pass changed or did you change
your mind or both our party has put
forward a position which will be agreed
at conference and we will take that
forward and we will vote accordingly in
Parliament and I hope if the government
cannot deliver on our six tests they
should frankly get out of the way and
have a general election so it does sound
like you are at a position where some of
your illustrious predecessors wanted you
to be when did you discover your inner
Blair right I'm in a position to lead
and very proud to lead a very democratic
party of the biggest membership has ever
been in my lifetime at the biggest
conference the Labour Party has ever had
this party is rooted in every community
in the country and those people have
come together all of them as delegates
and said they are there to represent
their communities and we will act
accordingly in Parliament do you accept
that you have sabotage the Prime
Minister's checkers negotiation that
Michele Barney a Saturn Brussels will
say wow we don't need to give anything
Sudama krob because the opposition is
sat there promising an option to
quite the opposite isn't the function of
opposition to challenge the government
isn't the function of opposition to
speak up for the people who the
government won't speak up for isn't the
function of opposition to try and
improve people's lives while this
government is wasting away through a
economic policy of austerity and a
failure to agree anything with the
European Union so you're talking about
possibility of general election you'll
know Sky News has launched a campaign to
try and in short an independent
commission to guarantee TV debates
between leaders of parties we've always
wanted debates between leaders not just
the party leaders but also with the
spokespersons for different departments
and so that there is an open public
debate and in the last general election
I attended the cambridge debate I was
there at those debates the Prime
Minister chose not to turn up I think
that was a terrible shame and I do think
there were two debates in fact that the
Prime Minister should have been there 90
semitism do you accept any personal
responsibility do you have regrets for
how this has transpired I have spent my
life fighting racism
I will die fighting racism anti-semitism
is totally appalling wrong and a scourge
in our society as as a matter of fact is
any other form of racism I've had a lot
of things thrown at me over the summer
although regret is the stuff that's been
thrown at me in the ill-informed nature
of it thank you very much for so much
appreciate thank you